the triangles below are similar find the
missing length in triangle b
e g so the missing length is right here
we're calling it length x
so similar triangles two ways to think
about similar triangles all of the
corresponding angles are congruent and
we see that here this angle corresponds
to that angle and they're the same
because they have the same one arc there
this angle corresponds to this angle
they both have the two arcs there and
both of these have a measure of 90
degrees they're both right angles the
other way to think about similar
triangles is that the ratio between
corresponding sides are is the same so
for example this side right over here b
e
b e is between the right angle right
over here and this one arc angle right
over there that side corresponds to t a
let me write that down so b e
i'll do it down here i'll do it right
over here
side b e
corresponds
corresponds to side
corresponds to side ta and we know
because this angle corresponds to that
angle that angle corresponds to that
angle and these sides are the ones in
between them we also know that side e x
which is the one that we have to figure
out the length of
we also know that side e x right over or
actually i should say eg
we know that side eg over here
corresponds to it's between the right
angle and the double arc angle between
the right angle and the double arc angle
it corresponds to side ap
it corresponds to side ap and we know
from similar triangles that the ratio
between corresponding sides has to be
the same so for example the ratio
between be and ta has to be the same as
the ratio between eg and ap so let's
just write that down the ratio between b
e and let me write it down here actually
so i have a little bit more space the
ratio
between segment b e
and segment ta
and segment ta
has to be equal to the ratio between
segment
do that in blue between segment eg
between segment eg
and segment ap
and we know the length of b e
we know that that is equal to nine this
is equal to nine to give us that right
over there and we know that t a is equal
to three this is equal to three so nine
over three has got to be equal to eg
over ap and we also know what ap is ap
they give us right over there is length
4.
so this boils down to 9 divided by 3
which is just 3 must be equal to
eg when eg actually let's just call that
x since they call it x this is going to
be equal to x it is equal to x over 4.
eg is x ap
is 4. and to solve this for x you just
have to multiply both sides by 4.
you multiply both sides by 4.
these fours cancel out this becomes 12.
so you get x must be equal to 12 which
is the missing length on this triangle
right over here